like a play-doh arrow aimed at the
tracksuit mafia episode 3 of hawkeye
made a big impact even if there wasn't
as much to digest in this installment as
the two previous ones regarding easter
eggs and world building that does not
mean the shorter episode didn't hold its
weight episode 3 yet again proved that
street level action and storytelling are
just as compelling and exciting as the
flashier intergalactic mcu stories
picture this
[Applause]
in purple
wow
in this episode we got a deeper look at
echo aka maya lopez and her roots
watched the bond grow deeper between
clint and kate and got a bombshell
dropped on us about a major player yet
to be revealed episode 3 does
wonderfully what so many movies and
television shows fail at when
introducing a new comic book character
to the screen we're looking at you
eternals we were given a well-rounded
intro to maya's beginnings from a young
girl to a strong woman in just a few
minutes the show kicks off in the past
where we see young maya sitting in class
seemingly the only deaf student although
she doesn't correctly follow the
teacher's instructions maya still proves
herself a very intelligent and creative
youngster flash forward to the future
but still in the past as far as the
hawkeye story goes and we learn that
maya's prosthetic leg in no way hinders
her ability to kick ass in a boxing ring
episode 3's disability representation
was stellar especially given the echo in
the comics is not an amputee but actress
alaqua cox is we also get a sense of the
loving relationship between maya and her
father william there's a strong bond
there and william explains to his
daughter that she has to live in two
worlds as a deaf person while the duo
seem like a great pair we are reminded
that they are involved in some sort of
criminal enterprise and parts of the
tracksuit mafia we also see ronin taking
out a bunch of the tracksuit thugs in a
flashback with his blade ultimately
wiping out william as maya watches her
father take his last breath we now know
why she and the track suits are so
invested in tracking down ronin a big
takeaway from episode 3 is a brief
exchange between clint and maya while
she questions him about ronin clint
claims that ronin is dead and he was
killed by black widow while we the
viewers know what this means
metaphorically echo takes it more
literally and isn't buying it she is
desperate to track down the person
responsible for her father's death and
she isn't leaving it alone due to
clint's confession she also suggests to
clinton that he should remove his
hearing aid as it will help him fight
better clint's hearing loss story is
peppered throughout the episode and
gives us a great sense of an internal
battle he's fighting after some cool
fight choreography clint and kate
managed to escape the toy store then
hotwire a car in the parking lot they're
followed by echo and her henchmen in one
of the best car chases in the mcu to
date clint drives as kate shoots arrows
at their enemies and each new arrow does
something entirely different some are
totally silly some are super useful and
some just have that wow factor you know
the one we're talking about mcu fans
love a good easter egg and one was not
so subtly hiding in episode three kate
and clint are about to be crushed by one
of the tracksuit mafia's vehicles when
the latter whips out an arrow that reads
pyrm as in hank pym the og ant-man kate
fires an arrow of her own that's a
run-of-the-mill stick with a point but
when the arrows meet the bim particles
blow up gates to the size of a 747 that
pins the truck to the street it's cool
to get a better look at what clint's
been carrying in that quiver all this
time finally let's get to that brief
episode 3 moment that everyone will be
talking about ekko has a short
conversation with her right-hand man
kazee that includes a seriously exciting
teaser when karzi tells ekko they need
to call it with the whole hunting down
ronin thing he mentions that uncle might
feel a certain way about their recent
adventures after reminding carzi that
she's in charge the topic of this
mysterious man is dropped altogether
while the writers might be trying to
trick viewers into thinking kazi is
alluding to jack loyal marvel fans know
that this is a hint at someone bigger in
the comics ekko is the adoptive daughter
of wilson fisk aka kingpin for some time
now there have been rumors that suggest
vincent d'onofrio might join the series
reprising his role as fisk from the
daredevil netflix series dinafrio wasn't
credited in this episode and maybe it's
just us but it sure sounded like him in
that echo flashback
[Music]
we're more on track than ever to see
this fan theory come to life and with a
special cameo rumored to occur in
episode four's post-credits scene we
have a pretty good idea of who that's
going to be it looks like jack might be
a red herring and our big bad is kingpin
after all is he the fat man of fat man
auto repair he is hoping we're also not
too sure about you either eleanor bishop
but more on kate's mom next week
hopefully new episodes of hawkeye drop
every wednesday on disney plus
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
hawkeye are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one